[Music]
i met jeremy deutch a whole bunch of
years ago and one thing which you will
soon find out
he is wonderful
he's a character he is also a bottomless
pit
of american presidential information and
trivia
so for this president's day i thought to
bring my friend jeremy on to teach us
all a thing or two about our past
presidents and some of their strange
habits
this
is a bit of optimism
i can't tell you how excited i have been
to talk to you you're one of my favorite
people to talk to because you have an
encyclopedic
brain an encyclopedic knowledge of
obscure things in american history and
our presidents
and i always learn something every time
i talk to you so i thought i should not
be selfish with these conversations i
should share you and your knowledge tell
me about john quincy adams he's your
favorite right
oh yeah i get excited about this guy
because he if you read what he wrote in
his inauguration speech it was like very
progressive things you know he was
talking about ending slavery in the
territories this is 1824
please know that
if you look at the first eight
presidents or so and you look at our
founding fathers and john quincy adams
not a founding father his father was
john adams but of the eight john adams
and john quincy adams were the only ones
that did not own slaves
now think about that they uh sure they
were from the north but they were big
you know abolitionists and abigail adams
was probably the strongest voice in the
adams family there on um a very very
strong anti-slavery uh platform so he
you know in his inauguration wanted to
talk about abolishing slavery uh you
know in the territories like kind of a
containment strategy that we see later
with president lincoln uh you know
certainly adopted earlier by the whigs
but uh he also talked simon about
a national school system and a national
road system i mean again 1824 we we
didn't see a national road system until
eisenhower in 56 right in the interstate
so this was a person who was a a big
academic like his dad uh just an
intellectual giant
uh arrogant like his dad he wanted to
make certain everybody knew he was the
smartest guy in the room and unlike his
dad who had a little bit of a sense of
humor john quincy adams no sense of
humor at all so like a really tough time
what happened to him after his one-term
presidency well this is where it gets
really cool and hopefully we still have
your listeners okay
he was really devastated i think they
would during his presidency and
afterwards i think some would probably
say there's clinical depression very sad
what is he going to do
his parents were very tough on him okay
and he started writing a biography about
his dad
and working on some other things he's
like nah i'm not fulfilled and then he
um he he found his why and it was this
it was
getting elected to congress yeah that
was tactical thing but he was like kind
of her first single-issue candidate
and that was to end slavery wait he went
from being the president to going to
congress
correct wow that doesn't happen very
often no they're the only one to do it
and actually simon is he served 18 years
uh in the house
and
many would probably say the impact that
he had was super significant and here's
where i get super excited about john
quincy adams there was a a gag order i
believe it was in fact for 16 years
where you were not allowed to mention
the word slavery not on the house floor
not in committees
and if you did you could be you you know
censured right there would be some type
of rebuke
towards you you could potentially
be expelled from the house wow and
thrown out of congress if you mention
the word slavery well you know john
quincy adams i'm the former president
united states who is going to kick me
out okay and he actually does something
quite brilliant he drafts like a
resolution
and he mentions the word slavery as many
times as you can humanly mention it in
in in one document okay and
now he's going to be censured
potentially expelled from the house
but here's the beautiful thing he had
unlimited time to defend himself
so he spent
two weeks
giving these speeches
on the floor of the us house of
representatives talking about how
horrible
slavery was how it needs to be ended
and
that day they would his supporters would
take his speeches and they would turn
them into pamphlets and they would
distribute the pamphlets to citizens
because they were trying to change the
tide on public opinion on slavery and
this was all driven
by john quincy adams and in fact it took
him eight years but he defeated the gag
rule and
once again the word slavery was allowed
to be mentioned in the house
um i'll tell you the other thing and
and
do you remember uh did you see the movie
amistad
yes yes
okay well so
he was the one
okay who defended the slaves and the
mutiny that occurred on that ship and he
did a pro bono he didn't charge and he
gave
two
days of oral arguments the case made it
all the way to the supreme court he gave
two days of oral arguments
uh he was victorious
and that was the type of guy
john quincy adams was one of the things
that i don't think a lot of people
realize is how the debate and the
discomfort of slavery
how much
it has been present throughout the
history of this nation that it was
contentious for our whole history to the
point where they banned the mention of
the word on the house floor is
astonishing because they just didn't
even want to talk about it how do you
get enough votes to restrict a word that
needs to be talked about on the house
floor where they're you know and it
takes the courage of john quincy adams
to put his career on the line and maybe
someone else couldn't have done it he
just had to have been a former president
i'd have to go back and look but i think
the gag order was in effect for 16 years
wow and i think
this tension that you talk about well
that also created the rift between
jefferson and adams you know if you
famously hear about that they were
friends and then they weren't friends
you look at the tension and i think
historians would say jefferson became
very envious of atoms because adams
really believed in the horrors of
slavery and that
people
should not be slaves period full stop
right
and you know thomas jefferson wrote
about all men are created equal
but did he really believe that all
a lot of
former presidents
when they passed away
they freed their slaves
but
thomas jefferson didn't do that
i think you're spot on since before a
country was founded and certainly all
the way through the civil war and then
even
after the civil war this nation has a
complicated history and i and we're in a
period now
where one side romanticizes our history
and the other side demonizes it
and i think both are right there are
some progressive and romantic ideals
that come from our history but there's
some darkness as well
we have a checkered past that make us
who we are
one of the reasons i like talking to you
is sure it's fun to talk about obscure
presidents and all the kooky things that
happened but i think it reminds us just
of the fragility of a nation and the
fragility of the people who lead it
alcoholics and murder and intrigue and
subtrofuge and back office deals like
these are not new things and they are
part of our history i think the
important thing is not to necessarily
weigh in on it but rather to know about
it
because i think knowing about the past
informs how we deal with the current
state you're absolutely right and
there's a checkered past and it's
important that we study it and it's
important that we lift up
the heroes that you know again i come
back to john quincy adams and there's
many more that had the courage to say
no this is wrong this is 1824. look
where they were look how visionary they
were and calling it out those heroes
risked their careers
to do something that they believed was
the right thing to do you know like lbj
lyndon johnson
lost the south the democrats ruled the
south
and he did what the right thing to do
was for civil rights knowing he would
completely destroy his own political
career but he would also lose the south
and i don't know of a politician now
who'd risk the party's presence in any
area in this country because it was the
right thing to do and he was a
complicated figure as well
very complicated i mean we can talk
hours about lbj who's fascinating and
he was one of the most effective
majority leaders ever you know um what
he was able to accomplish and certainly
the tragic passing and assassination of
kennedy but in the first six months he
accomplished more legislatively than the
kennedys did in three years right i mean
you can go on and on and in that spot on
i think it's the courage
to stand up and the willingness to know
that this may not be popular and i may
lose everything that that i have and if
you study
our first impeachment andrew johnson so
he was impeached and only survived the
senate vote of conviction by one vote
right correct and he was a he was a
democrat lincoln was a republican um
johnson not many people liked him in
fact when
he was sworn in as vice president he was
so drunk
at the inauguration
he barely could take the oath
and he was asking like who's the
secretary
of war who are these other cabinet
members and they had to do this whole
thing to kind of cover up and they said
no no his back he was in pain he was on
medicine he wasn't drunk and in fact
they he it was such an embarrassing
period that he left dc for like 100 days
and they had to go and find him after
lincoln was assassinated i believe he
was
drunk again it was like a really bad
situation he was not popular congress
couldn't stand this guy
you say they fell by by one vote well
republicans had the votes they had two
thirds of the votes to impeach him i
think they had like 13 they had a buffer
of 13. and guess what simon 13
stood up and did not vote to impeach him
and all those republicans who did not
vote to impeach the democrat
they all essentially lost and never came
back to the senate they stood up
they did what they thought was right
this is where i talk about one of the
golden episodes of the senate the senate
protected the presidency because
congress passed a law basically saying
hey listen guy
if you want to fire somebody
even though you appointed them and we
may have consented to them well if you
want to fire them you have to get our
permission to fire
anybody
and johnson's like nah forget it no come
on i'm the president i don't have to
listen to this and i don't have to
follow that and that kind of really
egged him on but really those
republicans stood up they did the right
thing and they protected because think
about this if that went the other way we
could be impeaching presidents left and
right because of their hr issues who
they hire and fire
and that was really um a principal stand
so who's the most obscure president that
most people forgotten about that
history's forgotten about there's a few
and there's actually a professor who's
studied this since 1970 and he's asked
like college students to list all the
presidents and uh there's typically a
couple that are at the top of the
obscure list
a guy named chester arthur who typically
comes in around seven percent or so uh
served after uh garfield was
assassinated but it's typically a tie
between chester arthur who owned 80
pairs of pants by the way which is a lot
of pair of pants
um
there was this uh general zachary taylor
you know it's it's a
1849
they're dedicating the washington
monument not complete yet but it's the
dedication
zachary taylor
by the way that's the only monument in
dc please know that
everything else is a memorial but there
can only be one monument so this guy you
know they do the ribbon cutting
he goes back to the white house and he
talks about how he drinks like ice milk
and eats cherries and then he dies a you
know a few days later and they thought
he was actually poisoned i don't think
he was and millard fillmore becomes
president of the united states
he signs the compromise of
1850
and the whole entire cabinet resigns and
fillmore goes down as the most obscure
president he was
from new york they were farmers in
upstate new york not good agriculture
his father
basically sends him into uh
indentured servitude if you will
he saves as much money as he can and he
buys his freedom
and then he ends up walking a hundred
miles
back to his house not all in one day the
only book he read
up until the age 17
was the bible
he educated himself
he was a very dashing
very handsome guy queen victoria said
she thought he was the most handsome
man she's ever seen
and uh you know lo and behold he becomes
president
and uh
very forgotten really really tough tough
time he was the one who created the
white house library
isn't that cool
here's a person who educated himself and
knew the value of education and we
created that and that gets you right
into like 1856 another
obscure president named james buchanan
you and i have talked about this like
everybody was talking about oh mayor
pete like if he gets the nomination if
he becomes president he's gonna be our
first gay president wrong
james buchanan james buchanan was our
only bachelor president he was roommates
with the only single vice president
there was a guy before um buchanan he
was president he was a franklin pierce
very very very difficult presidency
drank a lot before he was sworn in his
law school friend died they were going
to a funeral the train derails one
person
dies and that's his baby and he sees his
baby
his head
his skull crush right in front of him
and franklin pierce thought he was
cursed this was god's punishment
and he really turned into an alcoholic
and it was a very very tough period but
pierce had a vice president named rufus
king and rufus king was our only single
vice president and rufus king and james
buchanan were roommates for like 10
years i mean look i know it was a
different time and the discussion of
being gay was not an open thing but do
we have good evidence that buchanan
rather than just because he was a single
guy you know do we have good evidence
that he was in fact gay there's a note
he wrote to his house mother
so rufus king
is appointed
to like ambassador of france going
overseas you know somewhere right they
called them prime ministers or ministers
at the time to europe
and
here's a letter in the 1840s or so where
he buchanan writes his house mom and
says you know
i'm willing other men
and they're not taking my
advancements
i don't know do you want more evidence
than that i mean this was
but
no one
no one made an issue of it yeah you know
you think about
i think that's so fascinating i mean
yeah
andrew jackson called him
mr fancy and aunt nancy the pair the
homosexuality i don't believe was that
word wasn't coined i think was coined in
germany in the
1860s or so
so
they didn't make it a campaign issue i
know the parties their names remain the
same sometimes but their politics change
and we've had different names for the
parties but can you discern
the basic two points of view because the
way i like to describe politics which is
you know we have this thing called the
declaration of independence
uh all men and created equal endowed
with these unalienable rights amongst
which include life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness and we have a
constitution that lays out a structure
for how we're going to advance that
vision and the difference between the
two political parties is an
interpretation of how we're going to
advance that vision that's all it is
it's a debate on should we do it this
way or should we do it that way and
depending on the culture or the tastes
of the day
parties go in and out of favor because
there are points of view go in and out
of favor
and that's sort of how i try to explain
the two-party system it should be a
debate it's not about right or wrong but
it's like we believe that the vision
should be advanced this way no no no we
believe it should be advanced this way
but they should both share the same
vision
that's why they should find common
ground right because they both believe
and agree on the vision just they
disagree on how to get there and so
throughout american history we've had
the whigs and we've had the democratic
republicans and all of these you know
different names for the parties are
there two basic points of view that have
always remained regardless of what the
parties have been called that's a great
question
maybe it's
the
scope and size of government and i say
maybe
because look you know my background and
i'm a republican and you could say that
you know the limited government the
smaller government right that goes back
to washington that debate
yeah because it's it's hamilton and
jefferson right because washington also
warned about
his farewell speech you know avoid the
political parties right and you you had
somebody who was a jeffersonian thomas
jefferson who believed in a certain size
and a limited size of the government and
then you had hamilton
not president but very influential who
you know believed in a bigger larger
role of the government and that's
probably historically
been the tug of war
all the way to
reagan maybe bush but there's also been
significant i guess expansions under
republicans in current times regardless
of what
the parties have been called whether it
was the whigs or the democratic
republicans or republicans or democrats
regardless of the names they've taken
they've been two basic interpretations
of how to advance towards the vision
that is the united states one party has
always generally believed that
government's role is to intervene and
help as many people as possible achieve
that vision
and the other party has basically
believed that government's job is to do
the basics collect taxes defend the
country and basically let people figure
it out themselves and sort of stay out
of their way as much as possible and
regardless what the parties were called
that's basically our two-party system
yeah and the challenge is it's kind of
like fiddler on the roof when the two
sides are fighting and remember tevye
says well yeah he he's right and then he
hears the other argument and says well
he's right and then the other guy says
well they both can't be right and it's
like you're right right but
both sides are right and it's just like
how do you bring them together to do
more things and solve problems final
question for you
what in your mind are some of the key
lessons that we can take
away from some of these obscure pieces
of our history
that will inform or help us improve
modern day tensions in our politics
there were certainly
very uncivil times but i think you can
look throughout history where there were
civil
relationships
in a good way and in positive and i'll
give you maybe two examples certainly
the presidential transition of power
um is so important to our country right
and i mean james buchanan during
lincoln's inauguration right before says
you know if
if you're as happy as i am
leaving this place as as you are mr
lincoln coming in then you sir are the
most happiest man in the world right
during that period and it was a lame
duck period i think uh seven or eight
states left the union even before
lincoln was sworn in
and buchanan
didn't do a thing and lincoln
inherited a big mess from buchanan and
if you look at all of lincoln's speeches
and everything he said
how many times did he blame james
buchanan for all his problems
and the answer is zero
and i think that's really important i i
um
i've certainly certainly seen it with
president trump we see it with president
biden
and it's
blaming the others for the problems that
they have now
and i think again you know being
inspired to paint a positive forward
looking agenda not looking back yes
studying the past but looking forward i
think that's really important
and i think we can draw a lot from
lincoln on that i'll close with um
our guy who messed up the numbering
system grover cleveland the two
non-consecutive terms who
i made this comment recently i was
comparing again president obama
to grover cleveland which i don't think
anybody has done this is probably a
first on your podcast
and i was just talking about wow we
haven't seen like anybody's political
career go up so fast since like grover
cleveland and like you know barack obama
went from like state senator to u.s
senator to president united states
grover cleveland goes from like mayor of
buffalo to governor to president in
three years beat that
okay
but um okay so grover cleveland loses to
a guy benjamin harrison who oh by the
way has an addiction to cucumbers we
won't get into that today his dad yeah
harrison's dad writes and he's like hey
man you gotta lay off the cucumbers okay
they were worried about he said his two
vices were cucumbers and cigars you
gotta lay off of it but he was the
grandson of william henry harrison
william henry harrison was the at that
time the oldest president sworn in he
gives the longest inaugural speech he
rides like back to the white house
without a hat on to show how youthful is
and he dies like 30 days later pneumonia
whatever it may have been shortest
presidency his grandson becomes
president oh by the way his grandson
gives simon the shortest inaugural
speech okay
it's inauguration
and it's raining and you can look at the
photos and you can see the former
president
grover cleveland is holding an umbrella
over benjamin harrison's head while he's
getting sworn in
and grover cleveland says it's the duty
of the former president to make certain
that the current president isn't rained
on
isn't that
something wow
these are leaders
and whether they're president or members
of congress or on the town council they
have a platform now bigger than they've
ever had before to inspire to be
positive to do good things
and to have you know meaningful impact
and change so if i can sum up
the lessons that you so eloquently
shared
that to look to our past the lessons
that we can learn in our modern day is
play the hand you're dealt like don't
worry about who dealt it
do the best you can with the tools
you've got and act with civility amen we
can't create the future by clinging on
to the past
jeremy i
i love talking to you uh it's always
such a joy uh i appreciate you taking
the time and helping me and anyone who
stayed stayed listening learn a little
more about some of our obscure american
history and some of the checkered past i
really
appreciate it
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself
take care of each other